i know you just also got into the weed
[ __ ] a bit right but so shout out man
cause i just so much i'm high right now
we just dropped no we haven't dropped
yet okay in stores but we yeah we had a
little pop-ups and [ __ ] the big 41
gelato
type [ __ ] when you get like uh how do
you talk about loving the boys how do
you choose your
strain is it like yo this is the kind of
[ __ ] i smoke so it's got to be the kind
of [ __ ] i would smoke
because you say it's a gelato yeah like
like i do like gelatos but like but yeah
that's how it's got to be for sure plus
it's i think gelato you know like i feel
like ogs are like what i like to smoke
but oh geez ain't selling like that
because it's kind of like it is though
but oh geez maybe not out here oh geez
is not like
when we think of like weed like it's not
like an exotic flavor
you know everybody wants skit they want
someone a crazy name you know what i'm
saying yo you got some of them runts
some of them skittles some of that some
of that za like nah i got some og though
this is a small og every day though like
no jeez my [ __ ] i love og
gelato i feel like you know probably
more um
financially smart to go with
shout out to uh so it's what's it called
it's big 41 gelato big 41
it's all good man um
bro that it's crazy i don't have nothing
like
i got a picture